[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you guys might think that the typing was
an accident but that was totally on
purpose
[Music]
what's going on people waiting for King
and Carl call we got some stuff coming
up on the podcast I can't really speak
about right now but you know it happened
today
so right now I'm currently waiting for
caulk and King King should be here any
second but Carl got to go get the stuff
that happened today
no that wasn't that wasn't a that wasn't
me typing that that was an actual video
on YouTube I you're gonna see I could
tell you guys don't watch The Attic show
because I do crazy stuff like that on
the attic show all the time see I could
put it right back on look but here it is
see I I I've put it up there just to
just to give you guys something to laugh
about
foreign
I just got home like 30 minutes ago
oh here's King
no
they can't hear you yet but they can't
see you either because I have
I'm super low
I'm gonna turn this up and it's gonna
mess things up
a little bit
um I can't hear it right now
see right now we're waiting for for call
probably gonna have to join and process
he went to go get the thing King I don't
uh they can't hear you yet but he went
to go get the thing
all right now they can
okay
they hear you when I say they hear you
oh God bless
now I'm gonna be listening to this thing
so I'm gonna mute myself because uh for
some weird reason
you guys get feedback
on
the whatchamacola on my joint
I'm so happy that these guys are
ecstatic uh for something I feel is
gonna ultimately let them down
I I think
that this thing this is gonna be the
show that is gonna break this king king
they're gonna give us that back to back
bangers yo I I think this is the show
that's gonna break they back to back
I honestly think this is the show where
the where where the Fateful
start to sell a PlayStations
I think they're gonna see Wolverine they
think they're gonna see Ghost of sushima
too they think they're going to see a
whole bunch of other stuff they're gonna
see foam Stars foam Stars a little bit
of a handheld device some Spider-Man
information
and the fact that they're gonna be like
and we held something best for all you
PlayStation 4 owners Spider-Man's coming
to you damn day
and that's when and now
oh God
so I was messing with them uh at the
beginning of the show I I turned down
our intro
and I put just ASMR people typing
[Laughter]
uh appreciate the gift itself from Craig
uh and then we gotta find out from Dean
river let's see if IGN gives the s-tier
ranking like they did the Showcase from
June IGN man they gonna always say
PlayStation knocked it out the park
yeah the dog part
[Music]
it's an international boot lickers
[Laughter]
Dune
I have to just edit Cog on the Fly
that's fine
I'm the producer you guys
I'm the producer you guys didn't deserve
from the producer you need
I'm the producer that you need
I didn't know a state of play
oh wait
is it start on your end
where I'm gonna start on overhead twitch
I'm on Twitch it's it's completely black
except for the logo
you said please
everybody's like they late they're late
they're late they didn't start they're
getting the games of service together
bro relax
relax we gotta find out super trap from
Craig
whatever
here we go so so they told us starting
in five minutes
so so King you know what that means we
got five minutes away
three minus five minutes from the hour
they thought they was gonna get this is
gonna be a hot 35 minutes
let's go Nintendo we got a super chat I
don't know what uh currency that is but
how many cat games today
I think there's gonna be two cat games
it's gonna be a dog game
and no no I think they're going with
straight too
you think we're already right
cat games coming in hot
you see you see the king don't run from
no smoke got the fatigues on let's go
with the combat Crocs on let's get it ah
keep that right there on your neck
on your neck
where you gonna let up this is
reactionary Tale
it was like starfields in these streets
moving what can we do to stop them hey
how about we put a stay to play together
what are we gonna put out there home
Stars
I need to get a phone charge two before
foreign
stars and that's going to start at 39.95
I can't do it today obviously but I
think I'm gonna make like you know how I
did the
the number icon for last year's uh
uh Video Game Awards yeah that's coming
back first off next year this year but I
think I'm gonna have a thumbs up and a
thumbs down for this so after every
announcement I'll thumbs up how many
people liked it and thumbs down how many
people didn't like
and then at the end if there's more
thumbs up than thumb Downs of all of our
opinions
got it's got the iron silver
time to get message shout out to the 407
if I watching y'all won't see me get
disgustingly dirty
[Music]
Bernard King of her fractions is gonna
be there me too I heard it's gonna be a
fraction of the game
so would you guys
uh thing is not fractions it's factions
are you guys okay with um
us being at the top left
okay that's Sean hold on
[Music]
King give me a thumbs up if you can hear
me
tell them we'll pay extradite fast
I'm gonna give you something to drink
before this starts
well you better go right now because
it's only a minute bro
one minute
and my juice is right there too
she said what do we want games when do
we want them now
what are you gonna get nothing
[Laughter]
[Music]
you can get highway robbery
so we're we we're not going to talk
about the stuff in the travesties that
we just uh uh Acosta jar with uh not too
long ago we're not going to talk about
raising the prices of uh of a day and
day service wait
remember
the uh the Showcase they held back for
the show
okay this is the Showcase you know what
they're gonna show I know they're gonna
show Horizon zero Dawn the complete
collection for PC I know that
get your popcorn ready guys
Horizon PC
you guys don't want me out here today
all right here we go
[Music]
I love the Starfield poster
this is the intro back to back
is this a VR game
[Laughter]
no
that's the answer to the starfish
oh Sony what's going on
someone said it looks like me in the
chat
that's disrespectful bro that's Sony
falling down
this is not the game to start any kind
of event with oh this is how we gonna
start this right here there it is this
is it right there
the first one was PlayStation the second
far
oh this is a PlayStation 3 game
[Laughter]
all your lunch Nintendo thank you for
winning the date
oh hey Mike no no no that said
let's just take a break from my run it's
the roads out yeah roadside but no
worries grapple point
oh just grapple I'll grapple it
oh yeah I'll just grapple that [__]
with my grappling hooks no worries
grapple that [__] up oh just grapple
that [__]
wow so so this is what we doing cursing
PlayStation didn't even look at the
video
knee-jerk reaction to Starfield
and if is this what you want to come
back to the world with
me
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is your Sony
you're welcome
exclusive hi I'm Sean Benson that was
not how they did it on American Idol the
team is always on the lookout for
Creative inspiring and original games to
bring to PlayStation players around the
world
we are constantly canvassing game
development Studios as we search for the
next exciting idea and as you just I
thought it was supposed to be
organically done an example of the
Innovative spirit that we're looking for
in today's state of play we've got a
wide variety of games to share with you
my hope is that these demonstrate the
diversity of experiences coming to
PlayStation consoles and psvr too
welcome PlayStation players to Roblox
experiences
[Music]
who are you
to explore millions of experiences
together and to see what you create
you gotta raise yourself please
[Music]
y'all still can't hear me we are hey
it's something strange on your
PlayStation Who you gonna call
[Laughter]
the bushes
what y'all watching the stream boy y'all
on YouTube we on Twitch
I told you dude y'all was gonna be
disappointed and upset this is the one
that's gonna break your back to back
oh God
they trying to justify that crap that
y'all got
the thing that ain't selling
Ghostbusters rise of the ghost Lord oh
yeah and these guys mini pups you can be
a real pain
uh-oh more PlayStation 2 we are
giraffe
ain't none of this stopping the
onslaught that has begun
um you said you knew the link called
yeah like for whatever reason they're
saying it's streaming live but it's like
it's not like it started from the
beginning no it just started it's gonna
be hard for me to send you the link
because I have to expose my Facebook to
everyone no you're good you're good
you're good
you just go to the twitch page and just
put PlayStation in I'm near and it's
like it's like a video it's like nothing
going on that's why I need the exact
link
I got it now coming this winter yeah I'm
on point now
ten dollars from
Trail Billy Starfield haters about to
vanish after this at least
I already told you
I was showing up with the Army fatigues
when we are at War we're at War
we will not stop beating them we will
beat them into submission
with it
yeah
we don't have to go any further change
so far this is so far we are okay this
whole thing bush is bound they have the
RV of the resident that do well for them
bruh stop it Resident Evil sells well
over yourself yes yes yes here we go
don't let me mine the numbers yeah yeah
yeah yeah
the numbers said that that thing is a
failure
I don't know what they applied for I was
talking about that game oh no no that
that sells on other places
I just let you know it it sounds all
right here we go
no no oh Avatar
Avatar the game is for everybody this is
the E for everyone show again
I am not me don't get too excited this
is not just yours
but wait to calm yourself for everyone
I was abducted by the artist oh God and
trained in their ways
I can hear PlayStation dudes right now
this is exclusive
you
ain't even seen a movie
[Music]
for something I'm not even yours
they look good I must yes it's gonna
look good on everything else too
switch two coming in hot my world
this is a fantastic day a new Nintendo
was gonna eat their lunch
ah
I want to see something exclusive to
this platform tell me why I got this
what's gonna stop Starfield
nobody gotta show you a spidey
they're gonna show Spidey again okay how
many times you're gonna see that thing
oh for the PlayStation 4. okay let's do
that
they took they took the unused assets
from The Horizon
that's a tall blue aloe yeah I gave you
will you get that super truck real quick
yeah
um
see you got the 10 one already yeah just
the the one that's around yeah it said
uh shout out to Wavy kosher two dollar
Super Chat King is dunking on
Playstation LMAO
ony
shout out to the 700 watching me where
else these dudes
so it's a rolling
too yup beef everyone they got the
motorcycles this year yeah yeah yeah
yeah
look just like that on Xbox
if I would buy Xbox
appreciate the the gifted sub Craig hold
again goals Runner two
e very well oh demo available today PS3
now go get that go be the first to play
something that's everybody's
you see that girl
yeah you stupid
are they making their own
we got new controllers are they making
their own customers oh we're doing
design Labs all right oh man here we go
Mr me too
see if you see me man Mr me YouTube Oh
Spidey Joel oh custom skins and owlette
means
oh my God
just take the Wings off and let it fly
yo I told you they was gonna Shield
stuff to do
oh we got more the deep Earth
collections collection yeah because
we're gonna bury you deeply in the Earth
oh look another E for everyone really I
think this is the exclusive they showed
this one before yeah this is
Hell diving they gave him a service
today I'm pleased to shower an extended
look at helldivers too
engagement it's time to go into your
health pod and prepare for Planet four
drop them down out of the sky look like
otsst guys
they took Destiny and mixed it with uh
Halo ODST
for the drop pods
eliminate the biles okay we need to find
the Terminator oh the fog is kind of
messing everything up what is that
limitations of the hardware
we did this with PlayStation 2.
ah the frame rate don't look Sparky
right there
yeah it's exclusively trash
shout out to keeping this for y'all
this is going to be a fun game
yeah I'm trying to think it's gonna be a
fun game that you ain't gonna pick up
it's a fun game to laugh at on Twitter
who's out here looking for Battlefield
aliens
it crashed the stream the two dollar
super trap from Tom uh from tsunami does
Sony really have nothing but Spider-Man
they told you that
she doesn't drive from the angry
therapist indeed running on his m64. oh
this right here
this is nothing impressive about this it
could be fun as a Pablo Style
[Laughter]
somebody need to start pulling the plug
over there on games that ain't working
out
this ain't working out
your successful Mission if you thought
you was gonna crack it to them
so I like I like how the uh The Capes
Flow In The Wind Edge in the many
battles to come right
come on
now go out there and spread managed
democracy
you can't lie this don't look like a
hard PlayStation 4 game I will give you
that it's not like a super impressive
oh look at that look at that
what is going on who authorize this
is awesome
next year I'm happy to make it more stop
playing games keep it a buck they always
it's always been single players so the
fact that they leave September
here we go
and I told you I told you there's gonna
show Spider-Man
Nexus phone Stars let's go let's round
this out and close this show up insomnia
games
thank you for all of your amazing
feedback to our demo at the Showcase
earlier this year Marvel Spider-Man 2 is
filled with an amazing story and story
missions but today I'm here to provide
you with a first look at how the open
World experience is evolving and how the
game is built to take full advantage of
the PlayStation 5. oh PS5 folks the
first thing you'll notice is that our
city is nearly doubled in size with
addition of two iconic New York Birds oh
yeah Queen q u in Brooklyn
an entirely new mechanic that we
combined with web swinging allows you to
Traverse the city
or the fireworks that light up the sky
we and Cody out exploring these areas
let's go bring skyscrapers
Peter Parker's old stomping grounds in
Midtown High Morales his current place
of learning missions Academy hey miles
this is already painful Marvel
Spider-Man
what's next stop hey world
oh it's supposed to be fine that's right
do some sit-ups and get yourself
I get it
all over this
is fun all over this yeah yeah yeah this
is here you're here
you're here
thank you yes I'm here I'm here now we
back to the show
back to you Jim
come live from K N news
back to you Jim 25 miles I told y'all
what it's gonna be I said we're gonna
get Spider-Man we're gonna get that weak
fake handheld and we're gonna get phone
stars and that's it we out
brand new fast travel system as you can
see here the PlayStation 5 and its SSD
means you can move across the city with
very little downtime SSD the more City
you explore and the more activities you
complete the more ways you'll be able to
customize yourself that will sound like
no PS4 about time the SSD work but then
PS4 show up soon don't worry about that
on decks
said if those numbers don't produce
six guess who comes out five seats from
the comics movies
from Comics 65 suits that we gotta pay
for I don't like that 200 different ways
I don't like being monetized for that
you know damn well you ain't getting
that for free
no we got the last one for free which
was it um yeah
the last one was free I got all those
suits all I had to do was earn them
that's what's up I mean that was that's
the big part of um everybody being upset
with certain stuff is it it sucks
if you don't pre-order the big pack you
don't get like uh yeah you miss out yeah
[Music]
October 20th oh
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you good night
[Laughter]
one year oh since the end of the great
conflict
between Dana and Rena
all right
it's a great conflict
so
our journey continues oh this is like
some added game
don't let this be for everybody
out
um what is it what is it
is that game that came out last year
she's a monster
[Music]
it might not be
one of the Talos games I think I don't
know it might be just a new one Maddie
would know
you're cool
maybe it's a news of a rise and so it's
the attic exclusive
tails of Lucius and tales of around DLC
they showing DLC at this event
oh damn
it yeah DLC
oh we have nothing
back to you King
is neither visible nor tent
certain as the collapsing and converging
of the past and present
I called out
the future more dlz
you're adding let me know if there's
more DLC do
you think
nah I just got it nice okay that's
what's up yeah I gotta go go get him on
it got mine's locked up
yo let me know if this DLC at it
oh this looks good
job
is this the black Bond games you and
no this is probably e for everyone
has their limits
that's what I'm talking about guys
spaghetti
oh man yo it's for free follow me baby
for the culture we we gotta we gotta
have a stream on playing this yo yo yo
you can't sing Blues
actually what I was told that this is
really good reception
man that's crazy phone
you gotta yell out pause King
ass
look at that he ran up on him
move back move your phone away from my
phone
you almost killed me King
but they all hit those foam balls
try they trying so hard yo they don't
this look like that same game they did
was crash smash something like that that
didn't Panic yeah
but then they threw it and they gave us
a service it didn't work out I don't
know how Splatoon ain't doing the class
actions nah nah this phone Stars son
stars and we can't wait for you to get
your hands on it the open Beta kicks off
later this month before we wrap up wrap
up has one more update for us today
Final Fantasy 7 rebirth yeah let's go
she almost killed me she almost just
killed me just then
she literally almost just I'm gonna need
you to cool down okay why listen
okay I got you
the world's ending
oh let's go that's what everyone's
saying thank you good clown
don't like it
like it ready to fire sir welcome
to the news oh that's holding Rufus yeah
Goofy
this is the second one that was supposed
to be coming anyways
mama you can't hear that grand can uh
Cosmo Canada
and everything on it that's the place
right after cosmocan yeah so you know
all the PlayStation dudes are gonna be
like oh man that's ready that's uh the
reactor human in your hometown Neville
or whatever it is
that's the mansion look it's sad I know
that's the Mansion
nibbleheim I like my cat right there
meow I told you one cat we saw today
let's see how many cats we gonna get out
here today oh they got the whips yeah
oh they got these on them
already closed because I suspect they're
soldiers suffering from cellular
degradation this code uh Joe Gojo or
whatever yeah
this makes me really believe Sony's
dancing to their own music now
no that's that thing that you fight
going into uh
well I already played with Tifa we do we
integrate it was good on me yeah it was
really good oh they know they rocking so
he now he they're going against the soil
yeah that's the flashback yeah remember
when they were teammates that's Ultimate
Weapon
Odin odoo
I need my Knights of the Round though
yeah uh golden saucer a mini
what's this remember that remember the
boxing joint excuse me
that never happened in a different yeah
he still look like in a different line
though tell them
lyrics
yeah
oh this is
like this let's go that's what I've been
waiting remember got a chance to get him
hell yeah
I'm waiting missing back
oh that looked good
yeah right there
February
yes on two desks let's go oh no no stop
that stop being crazy
don't don't get crazy
don't get crazy
stop that
we ain't gonna do that y'all
ain't got that
oh that's it for me
[Applause]
I'm biased oh my God
don't listen to the goddess 40 minutes
don't listen to the guy that came late
okay listen to the guy that hosted it
that's right don't listen to The Attic
cause he's a stand bro
nah bro
this ain't the Droid she was looking for
this ain't do nothing that was happening
knee-jerk reaction show and that
reaction was great
oh God stop it Heidi and Final Fantasy
watch it again with disgusting your
mouth
all you did was give all pre-ordered now
get the [__] disgust we got the order
of October to pre-order okay okay what's
next we gotta be greater together what's
next
let's get back to back to it
yes again I told y'all temper
expectations it was gonna be trash hot
garbage only thing though I ain't gonna
lie Final Fantasy and you know I was
getting Spider-Man they show nothing new
this is not the Sony
that y'all remember these are the throws
this fumbling the ball
they have come into what what is it what
what's the Browns the Cleveland Browns
who have watched your franchise turn
into the Cleveland Browns son
this is the best I swear I told you hold
I came in the army fatiguez
imma walk through your Battlefield and
they'll get shot
they ain't got that Spider-Man yo yo
listen that show right there was a hard
three
let's get to what was the threes right
um
Spider-Man one
and Final Fantasy I give them two points
are three
everything else throw that baby steps
back on get busy
I gotta watch baby snappers give baby
steps back in here son
this wasn't what y'all was expecting I
told you Nintendo was gonna eat they
like Nintendo did
on them
what's up
it was it was very very mid like okay
yeah we're just gonna say what
that final Fant I knew I was expected
rebirth but that Final Fantasy was a
little bit more than I was expecting oh
that's my game of the year next year
let me see what's going on with this
it's coming out too early the game of
the year is going to get knocked out
summer next year it's gonna get knocked
in the mouth from about Game of the here
next year
oh this is the baby steps with the dudes
in their own
they keep in mind they started the show
with them oh no they started with this
okay was having to feel that wait is he
in pajamas
with the BBL what what's going on what's
going on
oh they started with this kid you can't
erase what happened bro
you can't erase what I've seen
I seen the champion you're on the four
gasping for air that Starfield got y'all
acting different
y'all tweaking and twerking in these
streets trying to get some some type of
momentum that was not it I don't know
who helped him craft this show and then
why the hell you put it on Nintendo day
um
Nintendo ate your lunch
this show is an afterthought I thought
Nintendo show was a a eight or nine out
of ten so what's your main issues with
the sizes everything else was trash you
only had two games
better than what than the Nintendo show
better than the last show yeah I thought
the last show was better than this show
this is
the three
a three yeah and if and if you got VR at
three yeah come on d a three okay
so let me talk to attic let me talk to
Adam I mean I'm gonna go game by game
with you bro let's go game by game okay
baby steps
hell divers
you say yeah
on Hell divers
you said yeah all right I'ma hold you to
that foam Stars
um
the DLC
DLC the other DLC oh you talk about the
DLC for Tales of arise yeah I mean it's
just DLC bro the other DLC
games that you don't play stop throwing
a thumb up for that let's go into what's
making you know what I got to talk to
somebody really objective anyway
let me let me get really really this
dude over here
he just yo he's just trying to make
content
you need a list but for everything that
was showed though like yo beat seriously
on got a number bro yeah that was a
whack show
trust me
you got a PlayStation V how do you get a
three though well I just showed you the
games I was interested in okay you talk
about the old so for you it's just only
again you'll be interested in yeah I'm
not talking about the Sony cappers out
there that don't even got the yard
that's going to be talking about oh the
VR stuff that I saw was hot shut up B go
out there and buy a PlayStation VR then
have a conversation so the games can't
be good
that takes points away from the show it
was an e for everyone show I get that
one I got it yeah yeah I'll let you
finish I'm gonna let you finish
go get it go you know why because it's
gonna be a three for me like this isn't
yo so I'm doing a dance right now right
so remember how Dan was out there
putting out sevens for no reason
yo this is a hot three you know why and
I'm being nice because it could really
be a two if we look at one point
per game that I care about mm-hmm
it's a hot too okay right what was the
two that you care about Final Fantasy
and um Spiderman Spiderman okay so you
didn't feel none of the VR games looked
impressive or good yeah none of those VR
games made me say Let me give [__] 200
for his VR none of them you know what it
did say to me he said I Told You So King
and legit RPGs didn't look good to you
the jrpgs look good but they look like
they eat for everyone and some with DLC
we need a list that's what the things
the problem is your eyes all you
remembering right now is Final Fantasy
yes
this year and Final Fantasy now is
February
and we'll go from there okay so the
first one
was whack baby steps right that was that
the second one was a VR Ghostbuster game
it looks like or something
uh the third one was uh VR Resident Evil
I look fantastic
uh then the avatar game that looked
great for everybody
that's for everybody what did you see on
the screen was it good I saw a weakness
so the game look whacked even if it come
out for Xbox I'm not buying it okay so
so just because that so now we do it
even if the game is hot if you don't get
no points because it's a multi okay
would you say what goes white exactly
everybody for everybody for everybody
this is where the threes originate right
yeah
this is how threes happen yeah you don't
have nothing that's only yours
so anytime is an Xbox shower yeah
then there was the three skins and and
controllers right then they went to
throwing their console into the dirt go
ahead uh then it was the hello divers
too mm-hmm whack
hot doo-doo
then I know why they call it hell divers
too because you gotta dive into hell and
go get Spider-Man
that's a dope game yeah yeah it could
arguably get extra points for how great
it looked no you don't get no extra
points because you showed it already oh
no this is the first time
the first time I was seeing it I'm doing
this it's like the third time they show
this is like the third time
rise to DLC DLC okay
VII
there we go okay
in a nutshell so for D gives kid gives
it a three I think it's eight out of ten
I give it a seven out of ten I'll give
it a seven out of ten I do feel yeah I
would lean towards your seven with that
Final Fantasy no the five things they
got the extra two points for me because
of how amazing they're looking we have
we finally got a release date but to
King's Point Spider-Man they showed
already there was a lot of multipliers I
don't deduct as much as him for both of
them because that's unfair to the
multiplayer because you know what that
means multiplies can't get any points on
any show according because if it's on
someone stage oh so what else
can't do that here's the reason I'm not
going
to crucify them they said this is an
Indies and third party show so I can't
really crucify them for not showing
something that they blew that they came
out and they came out and said it they
said it but what what are they talking
about well you see Davis
this was the second one
The Fanboys that what they told you or
we ready with sodi told you oh okay well
Sony told me to attempt my expectations
because this show was going to be whack
they say Indies and what is it
third-party stuff right right Indies and
wackness okay okay and I said right
and you know what they did you know what
I gotta be I gotta I gotta give him
another I gotta give him another point
for being real they kept it a buck okay
okay it's an expectation these we get
expectation points they they kept it a
buck they said it's gonna be a trash
show yeah but you definitely get a four
you definitely get that for for you
Sony came out and said we gonna be whack
we ain't gonna try to compete
um
we're we're getting somewhere he went
from a three to a four that's good yeah
and there's only two hundred feet hit
the like hit the like button let's go
let's get that up to like 300 before the
end of the show I think you guys could
do it there is definitely 50 of you
whole addict to his numbers man
make this man stream them whack games
bro make them stream them because he's
sitting here capping giving you he's
just making content this is content
right there that he like I don't play
these games
I literally did not cap for any of those
games though okay so let me ask you a
question remove all that stuff that you
ain't gonna play from the show remove it
oh it's gone
all right what show you got you still
got hell divers too all right so we're
gonna remember addict got to stream this
I ain't your guy to stream nothing yeah
no no no no no no no no you capping for
it it's you yeah
you outside with it I had one helldivers
streaming
Spider-Man
right okay
that's all I needed to see that's three
points
that's a hot three did they even show 10
games to give it a ten yo yeah come on
man how you gonna have people sit down
wait next to the TV come in five minutes
late and be whack maybe five minutes
late
it was five minutes late oh yeah they
were five minutes like they showed up
today oh I got the list I got the list
of everything it was trash like yo I'm
telling you this was worse than the last
show wow this was worth go back and
watch the last show
and you're gonna really be like oh hell
no Sony
I told you I told you guys
the house is on fire I explained to
y'all a long time ago it's burning it's
burning down everything's starting to
fall and you kept saying nine king
Everything Is Love Bug what do they got
to show me two wax shows back to back
okay
what's coming out this year though
what's coming out yeah yeah Spiderman
come on all right so it's not burning
yet not down yet it's that one of the
biggest games of the year is still
coming on that platform
okay one of the biggest games that Kings
already claimed it's his game of the
year
listen I'm a stand for her right I love
how to dance as is the world
I want the world to love Hub because
this is gonna be the last go-round for
hugs okay okay but we we do understand
this is a massive go around
go share it right so the house is not
burning
system seller console maker it's not
burning yet so there we go without we
gotta shut that narrative down that is
not burning if you have a game of the
year candidate that everyone is going to
buy including you and you say it is your
game of the year
exactly so back to what's really
happening right so we got that that then
let's break down the show we got
Resident Evil 4 remake you're not
interested but that is one of the
biggest games in VR Resident Evil all
right so I gotta pay 500 and buy the
game better get in order to play this
get it you could get to get down there
later I'll pay to 500. back to the Sony
text that's right regardless for people
who own the platform they have Resident
Evil for rebate deals I heard of them
sell well so okay it wouldn't be that
they don't know yet because it's not
released
so we got that then hell Davis I'm with
you King I I don't know I don't know
it's not I don't know it's trash I don't
know you ain't buying that uh I'm not
buying it you're absolutely correct not
garbage all right okay I'll cover it now
Final Fantasy rebirth that literally
could get two extra points for me I am
loved that one so that there we go that
game is amazing all right so we got
Spider-Man and and Final Fantasy right
right so you could that's I don't know
why we're doing points per game but okay
but
um all right baby steps I'm not I'm
all right so we got that Avatar Frontier
you buying that okay bye bye it looks
really good it looks what are you buying
it for I might buy it on Xbox because
that's the platform all right so it's a
multiplex so there we go but no we can
talk about it because there's a
PlayStation it was on there
yeah yeah yeah so we gotta make our
marketing rights if we wasn't on day
stage you wouldn't go into his coming
action no no no I knew it was coming to
Xbox but let's get back to it I know we
got it that's a great game okay so
you're giving points to that yeah they
get points I'm talking about cogs points
they get points for that okay so you're
playing that there's a possibility yes
on Xbox though it doesn't matter where I
played
is it on PlayStation or not sir yes sir
will people be able to play and Boot It
Up on their PlayStation I'm just trying
to figure out where you're okay so just
where I play does that I'm one person I
don't represent Millions no no no
this is just between me and you this is
and I told you I'll most likely if I do
play it on Xbox Xbox one no they don't
because I
platforms
so there we go ghost running to look
great I like it so ghost Runner two
where you gonna play that at most likely
Xbox what does that means what does that
noted no it doesn't work like that we're
watching the PlayStation show that's not
how this works okay moving on Tales of
arise uh whatever y'all doing that's a
DLC you know whatever all right so
that's amazing about that
um honkai star rail look good that was
the um yeah Japanese joint you gonna
play that no no
but it looked good it's not my style
again but all right it looked good and
then um what you guys yeah you ever I
know I now I know what you did with Eva
I know I know I know I know we do so on
and the last one was on phone stores
which I'm definitely not interested oh
definitely definitely that's bushes all
the way so objectively the objective you
gave it a hard four no
objectively this is a show between the
six and the seven and honestly the
reason why I wanted a seven for me
games I love was on this show and they
got release dates for the games I love
so that's my selfish
I am biased
for Spider-Man and Final Fantasy gets
two extra points for the seven all right
so because they gave us two points so
also you gave Final Fantasy Four Points
No I gave her kind of two points I ain't
get too close to two pointers yeah yeah
so what did Spider-Man get Spider-Man
got two points no no they just got one
because you sold out there Spider-Man
got one point he got he only got one
yeah you had a three point here yeah and
then I gave the multi-plus that you
didn't get that Avatar yeah right ghost
right now
why don't you do this for Xbox Xbox
though
listen your attic worry about today
don't worry about tomorrow
tomorrow may never come
today
oh my God
gives it a seven because
I swear
if I didn't know better and I didn't
have those turbines running in the back
I would have thought my toilet bowl
overflowed again oh my God oh my God yo
that was yeah I'm I I feel sorry for
them now like I'm at a point right now I
feel sorry I'm starting to feel sorry
for these dudes now like I'm really I'm
like I know what's happening to y'all
okay I'll let you fix it I think I know
where you're going and this is where I
do agree with you surprisingly yeah but
I do agree no finish I'm sorry yeah I
just I see where it's going and I'm
sorry that I gotta break the news to
y'all yet again
that
the fight is over bro like the fight is
over I don't I didn't see no fight in
him I didn't see no I see dudes damn
this is what Microsoft was doing Dancing
in the Mirror by himself thinking it was
hot and for a long time your dudes is
over there laughing at us thinking we
was walking see because you see what
attic is doing talk about all the game
is the show was a eight and all that
other stuff that's what I was capping
too I was doing that in my heart in my
heart I knew those shows was whacking in
my heart I was saying oh not like this
right so an addict in cog's heart right
now they capping but they like not like
that but but Cog wrote it down to earth
Cox saw really what they was about right
because he came in a little late so he
got a chance to see what they was really
doing so he brought it right to that
sixth the way it's supposed to be he
brought it down so attic right now still
on his love high right now and and you
know you know what attic get what he
wants
he won
when it really hits it's gonna fall back
I just want you to answer this one
question King yes sir
um did I watch this for you
I said for me or did you watch it for
yourself who did I watch this so I mean
all for Final Fantasy that's a 10 for
you that's it yeah you only had to see
nothing else yeah but you're gonna act
like you ain't know that was coming
um
oh wow Philip Carl out of the chat said
the Nintendo show with that's you here
Nintendo show broke this show hmm I
don't even know why they showed up I'm
gonna delayed my show
so attic addict said to you so attic
this just blow the Nintendo show away
for you
blow it away you bugging me you bugging
0.99 smoke okay okay okay so that's one
point you said what you you give me you
wait hold up name me another one
you want to do the Nintendo one point
wait wait oh hold on hold on Mario RPG
Mario versus Donkey Kong three oh wait
wait wait wait wait wait the Paper Mario
um
Jesus a Luigi uh Mansion um HD we've
seen that remake let's let's let's keep
going down the line let's start
murdering them let's start doing what we
supposed to do
they rapid punch game was crazy yo they
was hitting you after bank they ain't
even have to talk bang after bang after
bang after they was going back to back
and when they said they was done you
felt satisfied you was like yes these
dudes said they they showed that black
screen with that PlayStation logo you
said I can't believe it yo yo what's up
I'm seeing people keep tagging me on
Twitter apparently donkey made a video
about game reviews
oh really yeah and Travis commented on
it on Twitter oh we gotta go I gotta
watch out
yeah what was the last Super Chat we got
because I gotta try to try to catch up
there's a lot we missed this is this has
been a great day I appreciate everybody
showing up all right it's showing out
the last Super Chat we did um we gotta
find out super trap from God in person
Sofa King P.S on this door they are not
walking The Green Mile they are
sprinting down that thing
a a Ron Fallout Super Chat looks like
Sony exclusive abandoned has been
abandoned or five dollar Super Chat from
Tom from uh Tom from Toonami other than
do you guys get that Tom from yeah yeah
you got it I mean do you guys get what
that's from
other than two release dates one is
which delay to 24. what new things did
we see other than NDS and PSV nothing no
one is gonna question mark it up big
afro 14 10 ounce which I would have
liked this day to play more if it was
different than the last but it wasn't
this was basically our last day to play
with the same games just different
previews
Tom from Toonami hoags tweet okay I had
very limited expectations for star uh
for state of play but at this point it
feels like Sony accidentally uploaded an
old one oh damn Thomas Serrano two
dollars in the chat can't wait for that
LSM spoiler test for baby stats yeah I'm
good super truck from Lloyd Metroid
the Nintendo Direct was better salute
Xbox International podcast Sean Layton
come back please
[__] the difference between Xbox show
and E for everyone games uh they most of
the time is they're most of the time
coming to Game Pass yeah that is true
but according to the multiplayer rules
we can't count that no more so that's
over with it
okay
Nintendo four out of ten
that's it multiplages eliminated from
all good we go it's that's dope
first party first party first party
first party first party first party yeah
but I see what he's saying um my whole
thing is if you look at them
historically
they've always usually have what's the
next next thing coming the next new
thing coming the problem with them right
now is we kind of know their playbook
and it's look I will give King this I am
concerned even though I don't believe
the cupboard is bear I am concerned that
because they're not showing stuff for so
long that it's either a not ready and we
don't know when it's going to be ready
so that I think maybe they could have
put a hardcore something in a different
direction but a hardcore Sony fan you
know this is not a satisfactory show
right because it's like we're so used to
yo what's the next thing what's the we
kind of know this stuff already and
that's that's what it is so yeah I can
see why people are still maybe
frustrated you know saying for me you
know obviously you know I like some of
the things here but was it classic
typical Sony that I'm used to no and I
will give King that
okay so we got a last Super Chat
two dollars per shot from Fango sir stay
to play four out of ten Nintendo Direct
seven out of ten facts I give Nintendo
director eight
and That's all folks That's it man
appreciate y'all
foolishness
we're gonna see how this multitasking
follows uh when the Xbox when the next
Xbox
they're looking strange you guys they
like Sony so much you love Sony so much
they look different and at the same
you're in trouble you play Spider-Man
October and then wait to February you're
done son
go sit down have a ginger beer sit in
the corner and be quiet
you're done son and if anybody have ever
doubt me you ever doubt me now your
trouble past me I send a Duppy man up on
you you're not gonna PlayStation six the
Duppy Man Pawn you already I got the
Duffy freestyle from Lloyd Metro that's
usual Cog don't care about Nintendo
listen they're three other members of
Ireland podcast that don't get no smoke
for not doing yes
yeah they have a presence they'll have a
presentation if I have a presentation
I'm gonna tell you this it's Phil dumb
and it's Maximus are really expensive do
it with me if I think he gonna do
you're done all right let's let's see
attic throw him some pop a chair you're
gonna hit the floor you're gonna say oh
my God I can't believe it's happening I
Can't Believe It's Not Butter watch it
happen and when it happened Phil Dominus
Maximus are really expensive and did it
to you the Sony I don't look so normal
no more okay okay let's go let's go
let's get out of here appreciate
everyone
we are closing this out before King goes
let's go play Starfield
got it
they play star feel I'm